against Arjun Eric icy and here we go
Anish he only needs a draw in this game
but can origin are you guys say push for
a win
can we say out of the opening already
uh London system uh Ivanka you play this
one
oh yeah there's plenty of winning
chances but uh you can see that Anish is
ready to kind of shut the game down he
chooses to advance in the center with
his pawns and again he's kind of playing
the most critical lines developing the
knights and the big question here is
will he capture the pawn in the middle
if he's feeling very aggressive he'll
develop the queen oh
the night has come out to attack the
bishop yeah this is still well known
stuff white has a couple of moves here
white can even go and grab a pawn
um that has been played uh recently by
some strong players but this I think is
the critical move bringing the dark
scope into the center and there are some
tactics there there's some crazy games
that I've seen in the past where Black's
porn went to attack this white Bishop in
the center but uh no instead Anish
taking a more solid approach and uh
Arjun trying to explode open the
position makes sense while the Black
Knight is sitting on the edge of the
board and uh Ivanka have there been many
games in this variation not many games
uh but the games that have been played
they've been really by highbrow players
we have Daniel dubov playing it with the
white pieces shrinath narian nehal sarin
Jim by AF Sedlak who is an opening
expert on the London system so yep
actually most of those games finished in
a draw
hmm and uh Pawn capture in the center of
the board looks logical to me
um those games that ended in a draw was
this the move that was chosen yep okay
so Anish has done his homework you
mentioned that the draw would be a
decent result for him
and uh now I think the most popular move
is actually for white to also capture
the poor the D5 Pawn in the middle
okay so Arjun has a few captures to
consider you can take back this Pawn
that's just moved with his Knight his
Bishop was born but Ivanka mentions the
other Pawn capture uh maybe the critical
one yeah and Arjun maybe as well just
thrown by anisha's speed Niche is
clearly one of the best prepared players
in the world so he would have looked at
this before and that's maybe a bit
unsettling for uh Arjun obviously Eric I
see he is also happy with the draw in
this game with uh 24 points but he is a
teammate of the veditz they played on uh
both played on India one right during
the Olympiad
so will there be some sort of a team
feeling there well will he really fight
hard to win this game to give Vita
chances to qualify
um I don't know the answer to that
question I'll be honest I have a feeling
though that the Indian team spirit is
very strong could I think I I would say
that as well but I I mean it's very
important to Finish Well understandings
here I mean it means if you have a very
high placing it means you get to choose
the tie breaks the colors of the tie
breaks and you you just might have a
better pairing system so I think it's
very important to do
as well as you can and if that means
defeating a niche Soviet
yeah and uh a niche now just looks very
calm it looks like he's maybe just
closing his eyes trying to remember some
variations
Arjun taking some time and yeah arjun's
had a bit of an up and down uh
tournaments lots of wins but also a few
losses here and there he definitely
hasn't been playing Safety First chess
so I just have a feeling he's trying to
cook up something a bit surprising for
Anish okay he does go for the main move
that you mentioned Ivanka the move that
has been played before
and uh
okay this is new to me I've got to admit
uh is this been yeah Max's main reply
coming out with the queen it's quite
funny because there's been like six
games in the database and every single
one uh ended with uh Queen takes born
and now every single one of those six
players they actually developed the
light Square Bishop to attack the queen
yeah makes sense the black queen is
vulnerable
normally you don't want to bring her out
too early
uh if she's getting kicked around the
board she is the best piece the most
valuable piece so anytime she gets
attacked she has to run that's why we
don't want to bring uh peace the queen
out too early we lose a lot of time so
okay Arjun plays the most natural move
oh oh and a novelty no it's not me I got
so excited no no no it's because you
know something that had me
chuckling away was um what King Charles
said to Liz trust after they met again
and he goes back again dear oh dear you
know I've been waiting for the moment to
say this line you know and there you go
the king can turn around to the queen
and go
yeah so anisha's lost two moves with the
black queen but
I guess he's cleared up the center a bit
he's clarified the tension there we're
likely to see either white get an
isolated Pawn just like we've seen in
two games already today or we're going
to see a very symmetrical Pawn structure
where Eric icy won't have too many
winning chances
um I'm guessing here that white usually
captures back the pawn in the center of
the board
but uh yeah a couple of choices there
and uh every one of those games they've
picked up the bishop and they've
captured the pawn so they've kept the
pawn structure intact
yeah do we think Arjun is he freestyling
or is he maybe aware of those previous
games the the draws that have happened
in this position and he's just trying to
come up with something new to test a
niche with
he can kind of play with uh Freedom
right Arjun it feels like a freestyle to
me okay
um takes to the porn I stayed at Queen's
porn for the third game in a row today
yeah featuring a niche this time Anish
is playing against it yeah the previous
two times with the uh isolated one he
might be feeling a bit confused
what's this I'm not used to
I'm playing against this Pawn
yeah
you like this Lawrence well I mean I do
I I think black is fine but you've got
to trade carefully again a sample line
could run uh Knight takes Bishop in the
middle but then you give quite a bit of
initiative because then after Knight
takes Knight suddenly the night is very
loose on H5 and Bishop B5 check is an
annoying threat so you probably have to
bring the Knight back to F6 and just to
illustrate how bad things can get after
Knight F6 let's say Bishop B5 check here
you should probably block with the
bishop but let's say you did block with
the Knight you run into a standard idea
here the move Queen F3 suddenly white is
threatening the F7 pawn and if you block
it with a move like say like Queen E7
Suddenly It's Your B7 Pawn that hangs a
move like Knight takes D7 Bishop takes
D7 Queen 6b7 and all of a sudden black
is in Dire Straits so
of course Anish far too strong to to
allow that but that's the sort of thing
that you could see happen uh with with
slightly more inexperienced players yeah
and uh black decides okay no time for
that no normally you want to get rid of
the opponent's strong piece normally you
want to get the bishop path that's very
long term factors but short term you
need to get castled so uh very sensible
move
he's one move away from safety Anish and
then that stuff you showed there
Lawrence there would no longer be
relevant
and uh yeah I I think once he castles
he's got a very healthy position yeah I
don't think he'll be unhappy at all with
how the opening has gone anishagiri all
right
one game has uh finished in round 15
it's a draw between naroditsky and
Muhammad yarov noraditsky is knocked out
but it's been entertaining to follow him
and the preliminaries mom and dado
however he is definitely ready for The
Knockout stage he's played fantastic and
if you take a look at the current
standings then um
is on 27 points he could take second
place but if kukesh and our guys he also
wins in this round they will also be on
27 points and you think mama diara is uh
the one no one wants to meet in the
quarterfinals yeah I don't think anyone
would want to meet although anyone wants
to meet him in the tournament in general
yeah Mama Jarvis just on fire he's
checkmated so many of this field already
yeah just in the prelims yeah and anishq
he is also fighting to qualify with a
draw he's going to be ready but with a
lot of speed it if he wins his game
against David Anton in this round
then he will qualify so it is between
these two the bar now slightly over to
anisha's side
all out now
Ivanka sorry surprised by that
just kind of came out of my mouth I mean
I just thought he was gonna Castle to
the right I mean this this is
Brave right I'm gonna temper my words
and go yeah it's bold and unexpected and
I don't think it's gonna work out it's
gonna lead to excitement for us either
way yes
and uh maybe he's playing the man maybe
he knows and he just needs a draw you're
content with a solid position and he's
saying nope is going to be far from
boring this game for Arjun a win draw
loss it's basically the same
so castling of society wants to attack
the black king
but the white king feels the more
vulnerable of the two surely
what do you guys think
well it's uh if Simon Williams was
sitting here he would be extremely happy
with seeing that move that's exactly the
sort of move the ginger GM would be
would be looking to play uh playing the
man as you said David I think is very
relevant here because
you know Anish doesn't particularly love
a dogfight and and Arjun is saying I've
qualified
I've got nothing to lose let's have a
let's have a bit of a scuffle and King
B1 and already the move Bishop D7 is
kind of it allows white to put the King
on B1 easily and I'm not a massive fan
of it and the bar also demonstrates that
and now
playing G4 and next time uh playing
Knight E4 next I've got all these
springy kind of moves as Wyatt and this
could easily go wrong for Anish this is
this is not an easy position to play
you've got to be very precise I think
you have to also throw caution to the
wind if you're playing with the black
pieces and just
open open lines yeah
David attenley the his inner Yogi yeah
and later I mean there will be direct
lines open towards the white king makes
sense yeah makes a lot of sense but
again is this an uh an a niche type of
move is this what Gary thrives on uh
attacking
especially in a situation where he's got
half an eye on the tournament standings
does he really want to be sacrificing
pawns gambling slightly I have a feeling
he's going to play quieter moves maybe
just bring the Rook across maybe just
reroute the Black Knight before it gets
hit
yeah and like Lauren says very natural
moves for white this Pawn is stepping
forward gaining time it's going to step
further forward it's going to maybe even
blast open the black king and uh
also it's very scary psychologically for
Gary that he knows his opponent just
doesn't care his opponent just wants to
go at him wants a fight
um you know especially when it's a
youngster especially when it's a really
talented one like aragosi when he's in
all-out attack mode it looks like this
is kind of a quiet move to shuffling the
king to a side but it's basically he's
fully prepared now to step forward
okay so with the Kings on opposite sides
we love that is this a game that most
likely ends up with a winner
very unlikely at this moment
Anish maybe he'll find a way to swap off
some pieces and there we go he plays the
move I predicted that's a very Geary
type of move just quiet slowly improving
a piece uh very sensible but does it hit
the essence of the position
does it suit the needs of blacks pieces
I mean these guys are still very passive
this one's still offside and now I'm
expecting one of Lawrence's suggestions
either the night in the center or the
pawn stepping forward
it's uh this is something you could end
up getting in your chest boxing fight
Lawrence
uh
uh who knows I mean I've got no idea
what the what chess game I'm gonna get
with a man uh I would be very happy to
get this as white against Amman because
uh you know black is the one that has to
play precisely and when you've got very
little time and you're getting punched
in the face uh it's uh it's maybe not
that easy whereas the white moves come a
little bit more naturally even the move
Bishop G3 I had the corner of my I was
looking out the corner of my eye so uh
I'd be more than happy to have this as
white in the but the bar likes it for
black now especially after that move
yeah but
it kind of gets in the way of the pawns
yeah it's surprising I found a very very
surprising move because it's almost like
a positional move which you know
you won't even initiated chaos you don't
step oh you know it can't be done but
you don't tend to kind of go oh hang on
a second let me just look after this
piece yeah that's one thing okay and if
she is going for it now he goes for my
move I wanted her one move earlier but
okay you did it better late than never
yeah and I was gonna say that's one
thing that English Grandmaster Nigel
short told me when I was very young he
said opposite side castling positions no
matter what the opening if kings are on
opposite flanks don't retreat don't
waste time it's like riding a bike if
you stop pedaling you might just fall
off so um yeah it's it's interesting
that Arjun steps back and then a niche
comes forward so it's a bit like a
boxing match uh one side just trying to
kind of keep the status quo the other
side not afraid to try and throw some
punches yeah but it might end up being
one of those where it's a bit of a slug
Fest because there are boxing matches
where uh you know you're you're trying
to look for angles and trying to touch
and just
um outbox your opponent and then there
are other ones where you're both
swinging and this is getting into both
swinging territory black attacking on
the queen side wide looking at the king
side
um you know uh
sacrifices it's very soon become
available but I do like anisha's last
move
I'm curious what what the correct move
here is it's not coming to me
immediately you get greedy and take a
pawn or do you just run I don't think I
I'm I don't think it's in my DNA to take
that pawn to be honest I just I just
that's just against my religion
looks like a free porn Lawrence yeah but
I just I just can't bring myself to open
the B file here lose time oh my God that
not the advantage but the quality
everything else was just like much much
worse oh poor white so he had to roll
the dice wow yeah he had to get greedy
sometimes you need to uh kind of play
the critical moves you need to at least
test your opponent's ideas
see if they work in a niche I thought
he'd bring the queen up but instead he
moves his Knight so there's tension now
between the Bishops if we see a bishop
exchange then Black's Queen would
actually be ready to jump in supported
by the Knight
yeah I'm inclined to agree with you guys
too many open files towards the black
king The Rook can come in at some point
it's sorry towards the Viking uh it's
just so vulnerable
I imagine the queen ending up on this
diagonal as well if the black queen can
somehow check just give one check to the
white king it's game over
so uh already Arjun balancing on the
edge and a niche showing aside that
we've wanted to see from him for a while
yeah going on the attack even if he only
needs a draw he's playing on the front
foot he's good enough to do so like
Lawrence said earlier and huge threats
on the board such as bringing the queen
out threatening Checkmate on this Square
why is the defender now Arjun will he
regret that choice of castling on this
flank
I'm not even sure what I would do to be
honest it looks terrifying
um maybe you trade Bishops or I don't
know whether you bring the Knight to
stop the black queen coming over but it
looks so
ugly yeah
I will drop this bishop back yeah and he
covers the threatened A2 Pawn yeah I
agree with you it's ugly but I mean so
far he's surviving and uh aragaisi is in
survival mode and if he can just uh hold
on every single move then okay it will
be okay for him
as you can tell by the bar which says
0.0 but if I were playing this game I
would be terrified and how many moves in
16 moves I would be thinking oh my
goodness me
I might lose in less than 20 moves I
would be worried the bar would say like
minus five and back or something if I
was uh in arching shoes right now I mean
the most obvious move to me would be
bring the queen out against some ideas
against this Pawn but also some ideas of
switching across and checking the white
King on this vulnerable diagonal
this is just my worst nightmare as white
having this position defending yeah just
all the open lines but
you still have to Checkmate the guy
that's the that's the problem uh
white is still alive
and has an ish got that attacking
Instinct in such a position of course
he's
of course he does
when he needs to you he's capable
but uh okay he's still got a decent
amount of time as well that's a good
sign for all the Geary fans out there
it's just about whether Arjun can defend
and okay Gary not yet bringing his Queen
out this is the move I'm expecting maybe
there's others maybe you just reroute
the Knight you have to at some point
it's just too loose over there maybe you
improve the black Bishop somehow you
could just put it on a decent diagonal
you could maybe throw in an annoying
move Hit The Rook
trying to spitball some ideas I don't
really see
anything as tempting as this move
bringing the queen up
but uh okay Gary looking for options
let's see what he comes up with
he is uh fighting to qualify in each but
with a draw he's gonna be ready and uh
but he will end up in 8th Place with a
draw and he will then play jancrest of
Judah playing some fantastic chess in
this tournament in the quarter finals
Duda is currently playing against Magnus
but he is uh definitely going to be on
top of the table after the prelims
28 points that's a good score very good
yeah we've seen Magnus a mass what is it
30 something yeah low 30s but anyway I
mean anyone who wins the prelims has
done very well due to banging form yeah
dude is the type of streaky player as
well if he's on form just like he showed
earlier in the season he can win
anything wow he can be the best so Duda
and mamajarov I feel two most impressive
players so far yeah yeah tournament
yarov he has already finished in this
round on 27 points currently in second
place uh gukash and aragaisy if they win
in this round can also be on 27 points
so now the whole calculation starts for
who will play who in the quarter finals
Magnus Carlsen is currently in sixth
place and the sixth place plays uh the
fifth place
right no sorry the third place of course
so right now it's gukesh Carlson right
now there you go
I would love to see that one yeah I
agree uh India would be watching uh yeah
yeah absolutely and whilst the players
are pondering their moves it's an
exciting thrilling position but I wanted
to share with you a selfie from female
nurse so
I was just going to ask you all before
that's uh what's the most exciting
location that we've had people watch the
show from I remember a boat a boat yeah
we've had like Mountain Desert well
female nurses watching us from the zoo
along with the giraffes then she says I
just don't want to miss watching yeah
you've got to multitask in these days
you know you've got to watch the chess
and then go visit the animals yeah and
those are seriously cool giraffes
remember to uh ask them for predictions
isn't that always in the zoo prediction
for who yeah like the World Cup or
whatever
so female nurse please send us the
animal's predictions yeah I can't wait
to hear them what was what was it was an
octopus wasn't it he was he was very
accurate he was very accurate yeah yeah
what was his name Paul the octopus and
was that for the World Cup yeah yes and
I remember I was gunning for I think he
predicted England would lose and we did
and then there was maybe Argentina
losing and we did and Argentina did and
I was like Paul yeah it's not happening
here
I had a good streak yeah yeah so check
with the giraffes as well who will win
the aim chess rapid
and meanwhile five minutes in the tank
for initial he spent five minutes nearly
half his time on this one move and yes
he's doing some calculation that's
understandable
I'm not sure it's the most practical
thing though it looks like there's some
natural moves and white will have a
bunch of replies and no matter what you
play so
what is he thinking about
to bring the black queen out there I
mean retreat at night just whatever you
choose I mean this is the type of thing
I would do and then I would live to
regret it in 10 minutes time and if I
spend five minutes on one move and then
later I'm like ah you know it's a really
wild position I need that time now but
uh
okay what is Anish gonna choose still
thinking under five minutes now and
Audrey is going to be starting to get
very confident I mean he's got an extra
Pawn if you can cling on to it as Ivanka
mentioned
just gonna win the game so Anish needs
to be fast accurate and practical
it's going on his mind in his mind and
he's closing his eyes I think
very focused Anish yeah extremely
focused yeah he must be calculating some
long variation but I'm not sure you need
to right now
um in a classical game for sure spend 10
minutes here but over six minutes that's
a very long think
for Rapid chess and you know what they
say long think wrong think
um I mean what could he be calculating
just don't see it I mean just improve a
piece yeah maybe he wants to I was about
to say push this Pawn to get the black
light squared Bishop into the game with
a check
there's a massive threat on the board
it does this feels so the computer says
it doesn't necessary yeah just so
unnecessary but it either it's either
very good or it's very bad that's the
question that's the problem with this
move and you thank you you're right long
think wrong think long thinks always
seem to end up in mistakes uh they don't
trust the Instinct and okay he pushes
this ball forward clear idea of a check
that is why he's opened up his Bishop
and how can white refute this idea
this threat is deadly if it's not dealt
with
um first of all you could take this Pawn
with a queen you could actually take it
four different ways you can take for
example with the Knight as well and
after a bishop check you can think about
blocking this check maybe with a knight
of your own but this feels very shaky
for white uh I guess the most natural
would be to take with the White Queen
just to stop the bishop using the square
it's now covered
was anisha's plan here guesses to carry
on harassing the queen okay you're gonna
attack it with a bishop I guess but then
this Knight is hanging oh yeah
yeah what is his idea I mean this is the
acid test of his move now he's two pawns
down his Knight is attacked you can take
White's Bishop off but suddenly you open
up the white rook and suddenly check
mating ideas against the black king it's
not one-way traffic anymore
oh
don't see it is this idea just to play
really slow maybe just push upon and
reinstate this threat of a check
but
it just feels so loose I mean you're
gambling here there's no guarantee that
your opponent can't just find a way for
example maybe this check isn't so
effective white could push a pawn for
example and even if you get your dream
world with a check the white king can
hide in the corner another check yes but
the white king can hide again
maybe there's a follow-up maybe there
isn't but a niche four minutes two pawns
down in a moment
who knows what's gonna happen
um I like the idea behind the move I
like the spirit behind it attacking but
I mean he's uh he's really gambling
what's the niche doing let's go back to
the players on the camera
so he's making some kind of face yeah
smiling it almost looked like a smile
but it's just basically just not very
his style
yeah
um it's not his style at all and that's
not to say it won't work it does set
significant practical problems for Eric
icy maybe in that variation that I was
showing maybe I've missed something
there but uh actually yeah I see another
couple of ideas that were possible for
black in that position but okay Eric
guys he does take with the white knight
but this is a great move right because
Bishop F5 check 94. Ah that's the block
yeah and then you just solidify that
night with a with about three and two
pawns or two pawns and
this can go very badly now for Anish
very quickly oh his feet is out of his
hands what happens if Anisha loses
someone needs to maybe start calculating
the other results yeah and interestingly
Anton because I was looking had a great
position and he's absolutely botched it
he was completely winning David Anton
positionally he was crushing and now
vidit in with a chance so things are
very much in the balance now we've got a
very
very tense few minutes ahead
it's very tense for anishigiri down low
on the clock three minutes two pawns
down no follow-up
Arjun is just defended really nicely he
just took all the pawns he's just
refusing to believe the opponent that's
something we've mentioned in previous
days don't necessarily trust your
opponent on their moves sometimes you
have to call them out and say yeah okay
I'll be greedy prove yourself and that's
what arjun's doing to a niche and Anish
is panicking those two white Knights are
holding everything together
three minutes left for any Theory
fighting for his life not only in the
game but in the tournament if he loses
then read it can take the place and the
coach fans with a win he still has to
win that game though so Anish
it's not over if he loses this but uh
it's looking dangerous right now
I mean that's unpredictable predictable
right I had the video Anton game and in
a niche's mind he's thinking okay worst
case scenario that it wins
this is at the moment
this is where it all could go wrong and
video has just played a bomb of a move
in his game so hey so now he's in my
opinion big favorite to uh
to do something there so I'm in a good
way a bomb in a good way yeah great move
great move yeah do update us on that
game as well yeah so
foreign
oops he's probably thinking
I didn't need to do that that was a bit
unnecessary it's tougher Anish now
because he's trying to calculate of
course but in the back of his mind he's
always thinking oh the tournament
situation tournament situation
again this was so unnecessary remember
yesterday taking those drawers
it might not be enough now
and I'm trying to find a move I can't
see a good follow-up for him just two
pawns down I mean he just has to develop
some pieces you know just throw a queen
to the left side of the board
centralized no you can't even centralize
a rook
um bring the queen out this way maybe
yeah I mean I know it's a bit random eye
up this Pawn
what else what else to do okay F3
putting pressure on this Knight this pin
is his kind of Saving Grace his hope
that as you mentioned there Lawrence F3
is supporting the Knight defending
easily
you're running out of ammo yeah okay but
you know you could carry on fighting
yeah so he puts his Queen on a square
it's an open line
it looks active doesn't have any purpose
behind it I'm not claiming that much
it's the type of move that looks good
but doesn't do anything nope
and Arjun will stop bringing this Rook
into the game at some point maybe
retreating this bishop at some point
yeah it has no threats
absolutely no threats whatsoever but you
know still
there's an active
cause problem The Next Step would be
perhaps relocating the night
moving it to the D yeah to the D5 Square
for example yeah and now you have a
massive threat if white is careless just
to show a couple of pins this would be a
killer Knight track the White Knight
can't take this piece because of a pin
oops I had the pin on this diagonal and
the white porn can't take because of a
pin so still some tricks
in the position uh yeah you're right
Ivanka we should always stay positive if
we were in Anisha shoes yes we're two
points down but we have to look for
resources and Arjun might be nervous as
well because White's King is still more
vulnerable
than the black king
oh it's so tense this is super Tense one
more game has finished it's a loss in
the final round for Abdul satorab
against Vincent kymer so Vincent kymer
he finishes off on 19 points that is
currently one point outside top eight so
close but he's not going to play in The
Knockout stage of the satorum he is
ready for The Knockout stage but it's
been a tough finish for him to the
preliminaries uh hasn't won too many
games and lost quite a few lost the two
final games
today of this tutorial and let's see who
is going to face in The Knockout stage
well Arjun very natural move bringing
the white Rook into the game and okay
anishikiri planting a knight in the
center similar to what you were
predicting Ivanka
now it's not clear whether that knight
jump with a check is a threat but the
pieces are moving towards the white king
and the next step is just to randomly
push the a pawn and see what damage it
can do I mean it's very hopeful chess
but it doesn't matter and you have to
remember that Eric Garcia with four
minutes on the clock isn't gonna be able
to sit down and completely work out all
the calculator all the complications
yeah every guy see it's not 100 easy to
consolidate and simplify can you just
play A3 here or is this just way too
ridiculous I mean I I was trying to make
King A1 work uh he plays Bishop B3 which
is also fairly yeah
attack this Knight like A3 does it just
win a piece did you see the bar
the boss getting confused I was getting
confused now yeah I think you're right
Lawrence maybe you're just attacking
this Knight and this Knight has to stay
defending its other Knights and it looks
scary because Knight C3 check actually
forces B take C3 and then you've got
Knight D3 discover check but actually
after just some King A2 is it okay but
like you can totally understand why
Arjun didn't play it and maybe bishop B3
is a better move objective not
objectively but uh practical terms yeah
so he's blocked this uh block this B
file oh wow Anish Gary going on the
attack
Rook into C3 uh not sure what it
threatens to be honest maybe taking this
bishop but uh just to show the idea if
Pawn takes Rook then again a family Fork
of Royal Fork hitting the king queen
rook and uh due to a pin the Knight
can't capture Ivanka you think there's a
threat here yeah the Rick Chase Bishop
that you mentioned that's a big threat
for example if white just plays a
nothing move then Rook takes bishop and
you creep in via the A2 Square Checkmate
coming the king is gonna have to go
exploring the center and no King wants
to do that I mean how do you defend
against this uh Rook takes Bishop very
good question uh so this is the current
position Rook takes Bishop getting rid
of White's best defender maybe that's
uh that's the plan all along every guys
he just seems so calm though he's like
yep you played a cool move Dropped a
Bomb on my head I don't care I'm gonna
react
I'm not really sure how he's gonna react
maybe he has to retreat a knight okay
maybe Retreat the Knight back to attack
the black queen
and the black queen will move I guess
somewhere
okay he doesn't go for this he goes the
other way he goes in with the White
Knight with a fork but uh oh yeah
suddenly it's getting really complicated
the bishop could just take this Knight
the whole idea is that White's Knight is
no longer pinned white tonight would
step back and uh win material
yeah still the idea for getting rid of
oh sorry my R is getting rid of this
bishop and coming in
okay you're surprised Lawrence Bishop
takes Knight
ah if Queen 65 you can just go B take C3
and you defend laterally yeah defend
this Pawn across the board and wow
I should say look what Gary's did he
just flicked in a little intermediate
move yeah attacking the White Queen it's
just chaos right now white is currently
two pawns and a piece up but the queen
is fight Under Fire The Bishop's Under
Fire the knights Under Fire and the
white king not safe
who can do the maths there white is Five
Points up on the board but chaos
it's chaos chaos okay wow but it's
definitely going in in anisha's favor
these past few moves I mean
uh fair play to him because he found
some fantastic resources Brook C3 was a
beautiful move Rook C2 is a beautiful
move now probably you have to play
Queen's xc2 because
if you what what other moves if you play
Queen F1
just Queen takes D5 it was wrong if
you're away with the White Queen leave
that black rook in life
and it actually looks like now Richard
report is losing in the final round to
bukash and if he does and uh Anish wins
this game then the niche will actually
take seventh
a lot can change in just a few moves
here
and this is why we love seeing a niche
kind of take risks because he's capable
he's so good when he wants to be
and meanwhile the standings yep it is uh
Beat It hoping and he loses in this
round and winning his own game to take
that crucial eighth place but if Anish
plays a draw or wins this he uh will
take that final place
yeah so anything could still happen and
the more I look at it Lawrence the more
I think you're right why has to give up
a queen
or if I checked only move maybe we can
see the stockfish suggestions see what
the difference is between the best move
and all the rest Arjun now down at one
and a half minutes and wow that's a
massive difference if he doesn't take
that black Rook with the White Queen
giving it up
he can almost resign just losing
to that yeah he doesn't have the prompt
that we do the evaluation bar but
process of elimination it does look
sensible
is he gonna find it do you think with
one minute left on the clock
even if you find it I mean the
continuation is going to be tricky too I
mean there's so many pieces along that
line where
captured and uh
and
now
okay let's do a quick count white has a
rook two knights and two pawns for
Black's Queen
oh he's good at maths I need the
calculator again and it's a lot of
material a lot of material but white
pieces are dropping off and there goes
one night so now it's a rook Knight in
two Pawns for Black's Queen but now at
least you get to consolidate slightly
yeah Bishop B3 the Knight comes to C3
cemento as our good friend Peter leco
would say and white king runs away as
well yeah it's like it's rookie five
comes quickly you know uh thing things
can happen here for what you can you can
you can be fine so after all this
adventure you think this is going to end
up in a draw it could be it could easily
be a draw it could easily be a draw but
with both of them on
such short time I think there's still
one or two more surprises left yeah at
least one or two more yeah it feels like
okay Anisha attacks the white Rook very
logical Let's ignore the evaluation bar
unless there's a massive swing because
it's that type of position it's
so hard for a human to navigate right
now uh material imbalances when it's
queen versus pieces that's when accuracy
just goes out the window
and uh and he's dropping back his Queen
yeah he's getting ready to perhaps push
the a pawn yeah yeah
white King's got to run away at some
point it's too far out and uh out in the
open yeah
oh what a position what a game as well I
thought Arjun would just lock this down
just say okay I've qualified
he went all-out attack and and he's just
met fire with fire
it's very cool but what is the most
likely result right now that the bar is
very much in the middle
who knows I don't think it will be a
draw I just can't see it being a draw
somehow I can see all three results
being possible and uh well our guys see
Retreats the night trying to hold the
position together
oh
but I don't like that at all yeah I mean
it looks like a natural move
does Danish have
maybe there's something immediate maybe
not but the black pieces are coming in
black Syrup can improved Black's Bishop
can give a check on the light squares my
king not entirely safe you could even
okay Black's Rook could uh stockfish
points out just swing across put
pressure on that white knight that might
be the best move
just feels to me that the momentum is
always going to go in Black's favor as
long as you don't trade off too many
pieces White's King is still a Target
10 seconds
and he does build his position by
improving The Rook yeah and this is
played great actually since
well I mean the whole gamer to be honest
since he's given a chance to attack
we do have another result here so yukash
has won his game against the Richard
report to gain all three points
so that means if Anish wins this game
he's actually going to take seventh
place and uh
it also means your cash currently is in
second place he goes past Muhammad yarov
he did win their game here in the
preliminaries
95. okay okay attacking the black queen
where do you put her
to move her the whole way across maybe
give a check the white King's still on
that diagonal
okay no Bishop check first
and maybe you could even start
threatening some checkmates
white king vulnerable in the back rank
it's very tempting yeah it's very
tempting to take that white Pawn in the
center but it doesn't work there's a
trap okay
um The Black Queen runs away
just to show maybe one cool trick that
was that Elgin was setting for his
opponent he was trying to bait a niche
into taking this Pawn trying to lure
away The Rook with a background
Checkmate for example Rook takes Queen
would have ended in disaster but you
have to look for counter checks and here
we would have seen white give up a rook
with a check distracting Blacksburg and
now the queen is safe to take because
this square is covered you can't check
because it's covered by the bishop and
by the way what's happened in the game
looks like a fantastic result for Arjun
he's managed to get a bishop in in a
lovely outpost on C5 he's now going to
pass deep Pawn
um he can win a Pawn on B4 as well this
looks ah very very good for Arjun and
now the Rook is on the seventh line
massive threat huge threat so many turns
it's turned again and uh let's not
forget that white has a nice Pawn in the
center that isolated Queen's born it can
be pushed yeah and after Bishop E6 a
really nice move what about Rook D E1
here you can't take the visual because
of mate down the back and then you're
threatening even the move Rook takes E6
whilst D5 might also be good
taking the bishop away I think it is
good
seven Advantage for ergoici yeah this
one is coming if you move the bishop
it's just racing down the board
wow and did it happen we have a win for
vedit again
he has to make get a draw in this game
so have a chance to qualify a loss and
he's out six seconds no he's he's toast
here look at his face as well he knows
it he knows it D7 is just curtains
absolute heartbreaking we've been saying
the whole day is he gonna Rue that early
draw when you're slightly better and you
can press against a much weaker opponent
Gary resigns he's out it's gutting over
wow that went all the way down to the
final moments and each Geary is knocked
out of the aim chess rapid weeded takes
the final spot